Baxter's first words at the crime scene
were it was me you were decent and good
I'm not show is about Dexter who's a
serial killer but you know honestly it's
the show is more about the site the
psychology of of what he's thinking and
where he goes and sharing those thoughts
with the viewers that you know I don't
think any other TV show does season
Forza ending was was quite dramatic and
you know we actually didn't really know
what was gonna happen neither and that
we hadn't seen the ending until actually
aired we didn't know how I was gonna
happen yeah decided yeah this year we
don't have one single guest star arcing
through the show we have several so
Julia Stiles is one of our universe
guest stars little well Peter Weller you
know Robocop and who else uh Charlie
lower Johnny Miller yeah Johnny Lee
Miller so we have here we have different
guesses listen this year I think you
know the way last season ended it's a
lot of loose ends I need to be tied up
so it's going to be probably a
of a blessing it's not gonna just start
a new case will be a whole new
continuation Dexter's life becomes a lot
more complicated as well as the lives of
the people around them including our
lives in the show and I think that's
going to be interesting and I think
that's going to be that's you know what
drives to show this year